work falsifies you all the time work has
negative feedback loops all the time
people have good days and bad days at
work and so it's hard to put your sense
of self in the hands of another in the
hands essentially of a boss or the
market when you make you know political
interest to your religion when you make
actual faith in God your religion you
can sort of worship that from afar
without ever being you know explicitly
castigated by like a boss right and so
there's ways in which I think that like
the kind of work isn't that we develop
this kind of faith and work can actually
be like really sickening because again
these jobs were not created to
necessarily fill us with
self-actualization these jobs are very
often created in order to just be jobs
and so I'm afraid of people that place
too much emphasis in their work
thank you
[Music]
it is my distinct pleasure and privilege
to welcome back to the Pod the author of
the new book on work money meaning
identity you may know him from his
columns in the Atlantic or his very
popular podcast plain English Derek
Thompson welcome back Derek it's great
to be here thanks so much Andrew
Derek it was so much fun reading uh this
book in part because it was a trip down
memory lane where it had some of your
greatest hit essays from the Atlantic
including some something you wrote from
Ohio that profoundly influenced my
presidential campaign I don't know if
you knew that
um but you've been writing about work
technology
progress capitalism Leisure Time all
kind of uh interwoven together and this
new thing that you call work ISM uh so
what the heck is workism yeah work ism
is uh an idea that I had maybe two or
three years ago where I saw that a lot
of people who were middle class upper
middle class uh you know this is the
managerial lead of America uh who very
often had fallen out of love with
organized religion had in an age where
religiosity had declined made work their
religion so what does that mean you know
people say like you know X is a religion
all the time
um well I think that historically a lot
of things that people have sought from
organized religion like meaning
Community Transcendence
self-actualization a lot of those things
are
um virtues that people seek explicitly
from their jobs and I became very
interested in the degree to which work
had seemed to replace God in many
people's lives and I think that there
are some ways in which this is not all
bad it's clearly better to enjoy your
job than to not enjoy your job but at
the same time as I wrote in the piece I
think a lot of people essentially made
their desks their altars they asked for
much more out of work than work was
prepared to give them and that it was
becoming a source of both quiet
individual misery and broader systemic
berserkness and so we can go into each
of those but I saw these issues sort of
coming out of this fundamental issue
that people had essentially made work
their religion well certainly the
decline of religiosity has been well
documented uh and I I had a guy on the
Pod named Arthur Brooks who thinks that
politics is kind of supplanted organized
religion for a lot of folks and he
likened cable news Talking Heads to
essentially uh preachers idols
if you will and I I think work has
occupied this place for a lot of people
I confess that I had some ambivalence
when I was reading your description of
workism because I'm probably a workist
myself and I think that that that you
actually described and said look like
you know I I might be guilty of of this
even as I'm describing it yeah I think I
confessed to being a potential or
full-blown workers in the essay I
absolutely put work many times at the
center of my life I absolutely often
will have a Day determined in ways I
don't feel good about by whether or not
things went well at work that you know
when I'm with my friends when I'm with
my wife I will be in a good mood or a
bad mood based almost explicitly on like
what just happened to me in my job in
the previous hour and the truth is you
know diagnosis must come before the Cure
and I want to or wanted to and I wrote
this piece essentially see that part of
myself see it clearly and say is this
some is this a part of me that I want to
be a part of me is it a part of me that
I'm proud of or is this a value in my
life that I would like to downshift a
bit because and this goes a little bit
philosophically toward the difference
between work as a religion and even
frankly Politics as a religion or actual
religion faith in God is a religion work
falsifies you all the time work has
negative feedback loops all the time
people have good days and bad days at
work and so it's hard to put your sense
of self in the hands of another in the
hands essentially of a boss or the
market
when you make you know political
interest to your religion when you make
actual faith in God your religion you
can sort of worship that from afar
without ever being you know explicitly
castigated by like a boss right and so
there's ways in which I think that like
the kind of work isn't that we develop
this kind of faith and work can actually
be like really sickening because again
these jobs were not created to
necessarily fill us with
self-actualization these jobs are very
often created in order to just be jobs
and so I'm afraid of people that place
too much emphasis in their work well one
of the things you wrote in a piece when
you talk about Ohio's economic
transition and I I tried to document
some of this too for people uh was that
idleness has really negative
psychological effects for a lot of
people that experience it uh there was
one person you quote who likened it to
uh losing a loved one something along
those lines and time use studies show
that if you have free time particularly
if you're a man you don't necessarily
run out and volunteer more or do things
that people think of as I had a
productive time uses
yeah yeah that there's a lot of TV
watching a lot of computer use
a lot of things that make you feel less
connected so so that that's one of the
natural outgrowths of your concern with
workism I think is what the heck do we
do when you don't have work yes and this
is really well put because on the one
hand someone might have listened to you
and say aren't you making two opposite
points that on the one hand you're
saying when we're too obsessed with our
jobs that's bad but on the other hand
when we don't have a job that's also
very bad yeah you know this is this is
absolutely something that can benefit
from the you know Aristotelian mean like
people should have jobs it seems that
not having jobs is incredibly miserating
but also I think there's a there are
dangers in what we have formerly called
careerism workaholism that is being too
obsessed with progressing in your career
um too obsessed with working long hours
and then work is them another word that
I'm throwing into this sort of
linguistic jambalaya which to me says
not just about you know being obsessed
with progressing through your life or
working long hours it's about defining
yourself you know hanging your identity
on the tent pole of what you do so that
who you are is what you do I think that
is the danger at the other end of the
spectrum but the reason I think it's
really sophisticated to point out that
these two things exist
in the same world is because they don't
necessarily have to you know we don't
need to have built a world for example
um where attachments to labor force was
the be-all end-all of society but the
truth is we kind of have if you want
earn income tax credit you have to work
if you want some of these other you know
means-tested credits that are attached
to people who are working attached
essentially to W-2s you have to work and
so we have as a message topped down from
the government from people that are
making policy this idea that work in
fact is Central not only to your
identity but to your ability to be above
the poverty line if you want to escape
that world of poverty you of course have
to work until you're you know 65 years
old and you can collect Social Security
so you know there are other worlds that
we could theoretically build and a lot
of this book is about what those worlds
could look like
thank you
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
one of the trends that I've been
stressed about ever since I started in
public life I suppose has been the
departure of Americans from the
workforce uh so there's been a
multi-year trend of the labor force
participation rate generally declining I
mean it's had fits and starts upward as
you and I are talking right now I think
it's at 62 and a half percent uh which
has
recovered somewhat but is still lower
than 2020 when covid started uh I think
about 2 million plus Americans have left
the workforce post covid what's your
read on what the heck happened to those
two million workers because some of the
explanations I see
um they're like it seems like it's a bit
of a mystery but people say look some of
it is
um people leaving urban areas and then
doing things that don't show up as Jobs
some of it is women in particular
focusing more on family time and
responsibilities well so I guess I'll
just leave it there for a sec like what
do you think has happened to the
workforce in the last couple of years I
think to the extent that there is a
simple answer to the question
the answer to the question is
people just retired and they stayed
retired yeah so there's some early
retirees yeah that happens I think
that's I think that's most of it I think
that most of it is that people say
retired if you look I believe at the
prime age participation rate that is the
share of people between the age of 25
and 54 who are working it is more or
less back to 2020. if you look at teens
uh they've been much less likely to work
for many decades that largely isn't
necessarily just because teens are
you know lazy a lot of times or in many
cases homework is just taking up an
extracurricular activities or taking up
more time so they're less likely to say
you know work in you know the record
stores of 1970 and they're more likely
um to be taking on extracurricular
activities
um and I also finally think that a bit
of it is
um uh mothers in particular I was going
to say parents but I do think it's
probably specifically mothers
um who various ages may have pulled out
of the labor force during the pandemic
and somewhat stayed out of the labor
force so that they're more likely to be
part-time
um but my my read of the data and mostly
the data that I look at would come from
Fred the St Louis fed uh sort of data
source the database which of course
you're very familiar with says that most
of this is about uh Senior Citizens
non-disabled senior citizens who got out
of the economy because they were afraid
rightly that kovid represented a
disproportionate risk to them and stayed
out of the economy in part because they
didn't want to come back go back to
their old jobs they were still afraid of
covid they got used to being retired and
they maybe owned their house and liked
what they had in their portfolio and so
decided to retire on it uh well one of
the big Mega Trends over this last
couple of years uh that might have a
relationship is the move to remote work
which you've written a lot about so I'm
sitting in New York how is it in DC here
in New York uh I'd say
Office Buildings are half full slash
half empty DC I believe leads the
country in the share of workers who work
at least part-time from home
um I'm talking to you from home many
many people as I understand it uh are
are working from home I think it's a I
think it's more than 50 in Washington DC
and that's because to a certain extent
you know DC is a little bit of a company
town we got this you know big thing the
federal government that you know siphons
off two trillion excuse me four trillion
dollars of Revenue every year so there's
a lot of people that are either are
employed by the federal government or
like you know one or two degrees away
from the federal government and um uh
you know federal work is very
white-collar it's it's um you don't
necessarily have to clearly work in a
factory it's not like retail it's not
like schooling which you know it's hard
to be really hard to be I think a remote
kindergarten teacher um so yeah DC I
believe last time I looked at the data
led the country and the share of people
who are remote so in a way you're a test
case for something the future of remote
work by Washington yeah exactly yeah
it's right here I am the future
precisely so you wrote about how so uh
there are there's a need for us to try
and optimize organizations in particular
uh to remote work to replace the
opportunity for soft work
um you also write about some things that
I totally agree with by the way that's
like hey some of the drawbacks it's
going to be tougher for young people uh
to gain traction and Ascend within
organizations which I agree with
um and it also might be harder for the
cultivation of new ideas and Innovation
unless organizations take very very
real steps toward trying to create those
opportunities yeah I would say that
while I am a fan of remote work and it
would be incredibly hypocritical for me
to not be a fan of remote work as I'm
currently working remotely
I do think there are probably three
problems they all sort of come down to
this issue of novelty I think remote
work probably isn't as good at forging
your relationships at coming up with new
ideas and at bringing on new people into
a company so to go through all three of
those really quickly I think that
research seems to show that it's easier
to build trust between people who don't
know each other if they can see their
entire bodies you know when you are
slacking with someone or g-chatting with
someone and they give you a sort of
Courage response to an idea that you
thought was really really wonderful
if they just say like okay if they type
the letters okay in response to this
idea you thought was like really
interesting it's easy to get offended
it's easy to write in negative emotions
where negative emotions didn't exist but
maybe if you're at that exact same
interaction in person and you you know
handed someone you know whatever a
manila folder no one carries them
anymore but you like handed someone a
printed on piece of paper with an idea
and they said okay and it had this like
smile on their face and their body
language that I think this is a really
cool idea and I'm excited that you
brought it to me all right well that's
the exact same language okay on slack
versus okay in person we're much less
likely to take offense when we see sort
of the full data set of someone's
someone's full-bodied response to us so
in that way I think that psychological
safety is probably easiest to build
in person and why lots of organizations
that are remote have maintained success
while being remote by having a lot of
off-sites by having a lot of in-person
meetings because there's this
understanding that a company is not
really a company if people are only
talking to each other on slack that's
not a company it's a it's a group text
you know it's a group text that Pages
um and so I think that it's really
important
um to for these companies to have
opportunities for colleagues to actually
see each other and build that kind of
trust in psychological safety
Atlantic take note Derek wants everyone
to to I don't what I'm saying what I'm
saying instead is is meaningfully
different this is a point of contention
at my and many other organizations it's
not that I think that everyone needs to
be in the office on every given Monday
Wednesday and Friday it's rather that if
no one is ever together on any Monday
Wednesday Tuesday Thursday Friday that's
when you have a problem that it's
important for remote first companies to
build in a habit of physical world
reunions because people like working
with people not with icons on a group
chat
foreign
you guys already know all about
expressvpn I've talked before about why
they are the go-to service for
protecting your online activity big Tech
should not be snooping on us and
profiting from what we do in our private
time expressvpn can also help access
content including thousands of Netflix
shows that might be available in another
Market you just beam in encrypted
surreptitiously and you can be a UK user
and all of a sudden all that fun BBC
content can be yours I could go on and
on about expressvpn it's a VPN that I
trust and I'm not surprised that CNET
wired and others have rated at number
one visit expressvpn.com yang right now
and get three extra months of their
service for free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
I'm going to speak for myself for just a
moment Derek because I I although my
situation might be unusual whatever so
when when people send me messages around
an idea
um they might have or a company they're
working with so you know I get them in
all forms of media
um I might get a text message about it I
might get an email about it I might get
a DM about it I might get uh you know a
deck about it part of it is that if
someone is presenting something to you
in person you're just much more likely
to take it to the next level both in
your own mind and also in terms of your
Deeds your actions like if you get a
message from someone
um then you know like the the path of
least resistance is not necessarily to
follow through to the nth degree so that
I think there's a like a general
generation of reciprocity that occurs in
person to a much higher uh extent where
it's like oh I'm not going to be able to
ignore your thing because you know
you're freaking like looking at me yeah
yeah exactly it well it's you know I I
don't know if I'm sort of like making up
psychology here but whatever I'll just
go ahead and make it up when we are
talking to someone live in person
getting lunch or drinks with them and
getting coffee with them their body
occupies our full visual field what
they're saying to us occupies our full
auditory field we are immersed in the
issue of what they are saying and what
they look like
when I get an email from someone when I
get a DM from someone when I get a slack
from someone that slack at any given
moment occupies what five percent of the
screen that I'm looking into and their
Ike and the little Avatar icon occupies
maybe 0.5 of the screen and it's just a
burp it's just a message and so I can at
any moment click away and forget about
it forever so there's just all sorts of
I don't know what you want to call it
psychological phenomenological reasons
why being with someone physically is so
much it's so much different than
associating with 15 people in one-off
ways on a computer now I want to be
clear that I think remote work can do
some things that offices can't do I
think that commutes are by and large a
Scourge for most people I don't think
Community certainly make people unhappy
it's like the single biggest correlation
absolutely yep you know that you right
great you know that data right can you
seem to make people miserable If people
could you know literally just teleport
to work I suppose that could cut down
the commute time but it's wonderful that
people have more time with their
families with their partners with their
spouses with their friends to work out
to cook dinners rather than order in if
that's what they prefer to do I think
that time returned to workers is really
fantastic and frankly there's all sorts
of ways in which we might have
there might be ways of developing more
creative networks on the internet than
in an office because the internet gives
you uh or exposes you to a network of
thinkers that is larger than any
particular slack Channel or office space
so there are ways in which I think
remote work can be better than office
work but I do think that in this
particular narrow Corner that we're
talking about right now it's narrow but
it's I think very important
um about trust and about follow-through
there just is a material difference
between meeting someone and seeing their
entire body and getting an email from
someone and being able to Archive that
in 0.5 seconds I think all the time too
about a younger version of myself Derek
because right now if you give me a
choice in terms of remote work or on an
office I mean it's remote all the way
because you know I've got so much stuff
going on it seems ridiculous I mean like
go to it
and the rest of it so again like I do
think a lot about young people it's like
you know it's it's going to be harder
and and I had another conversation with
a guy you probably know well Martin Ford
who wrote
um uh rise rise of the robots
um and so one of the things we're
talking about
um which I'd love to ask you about is is
the impact of uh Ai and Automation and
you're one of the earlier thinkers
saying look guys like
and there's something happening There's
Something Brewing I mean you were
writing about it back in 2015 the same
time Martin was uh and Martin made an
observation which I thought was
fascinating but he said look a lot of
the most readily automatable work in an
organization was done by entry-level
people and so if you are replacing that
work or getting it done by AI then it's
you're going to look around and be like
do I need this many entry-level people
and like so you're going to have a
harder ladder to climb or at the
beginning of the ladder might not exist
in a lot of these these firms right yeah
two points I want to respond to the
first is I think he very rightly pointed
out that attitudes toward remote work
stratify by age and older established
workers especially those with families
are much more likely to say in surveys
they want to spend more time at home
especially if they're a little bit more
introverted whereas people who are
younger in surveys that are done by
Stanford's Nicholas Bloom who's done
some of the best research on preferences
by managers and workers on working from
home home he finds that the people who
want to spend the most time in the
office are in fact young people because
they want to feel like they are they
belong to a culture and a culture that
isn't just a group slack second on the
issue of AI and
um young workers or entry-level workers
there's two factors here and I wonder
how they cross cut on the one hand
entry-level workers just by Dent of
their entry level know the least about
their industry and as a result you would
think that's the easiest to automate
because this is where the AI the large
language model whatever technology we're
using the least amount of sophistication
is necessary in order to automate or
somehow improve upon the tasks that
those 22 year olds are doing at the same
time 22 year olds are really cheap
and at least cheap compared to 23 year
olds who are cheap compared to 25 year
olds etc etc and so
um the most profitable places to
automate tend to be
big cost centers and I don't know there
might be a lot of companies where you
know hiring you know if you're McKinsey
or Bain or BCG let's say you're a
consulting firm and you're looking at
chat CPT and you're looking at these
large language models and you're
thinking you know I think a lot of the
research that we've historically relied
on a pool of 22 year olds to do we could
theoretically do with large language
models now maybe you think that you say
you know we used to have 80 people in
each annual class of graduating college
seniors come into BCG in this office now
it's going to be 40 and we're going to
try to llm our way through the other 40.
maybe make that decision
um or maybe in the short run you still
just hire 80 people teach them all how
to use large language models really well
and as a result you realize that like oh
wow like we need way more business
because these kids these these you know
22 year olds are so much more productive
and as a result you have to hire more
business developments in order to drum
out more business for BCG so there's
there are also potentially ways at least
in the short term these very same
Technologies by Dent through
productivity could either replace work
or increase work because suddenly all
these productive people means we need to
hire up in our business development
office
foreign
tour is coming to a city near you that
means I'm coming to a city near you I'm
heading to San Francisco Los Angeles
Seattle Raleigh Denver and more in the
spring go to fordparty.com to check out
the upcoming dates or just check out my
social media primarily Twitter
unfortunately see you soon
[Music]
I signed on to this letter that Tristan
Harris helped organize that said look
let's try and put a pause on these tools
for a minute
um now did I think that that was likely
to stimulate productive conversation yes
did I think that you know it was going
to be effectuated uh you know probably
probably uh probably not
um but one of the reasons why I was very
happy to sign on to it was because
everything I was hearing was that there
are a lot of organizations that are
trying to deploy these tools in ways
that are going to
um hurt workers uh over some time frame
and I feel like they they think they
have no choice yeah how do you feel
about Italy Banning chat EBT entirely
you know I mean I so and that's the
other side like I talked to a friend
who's a partner in a law firm and they
banned AI entirely and that seems like a
loser you know what I mean it it like
it's just straight up
um protectionist stuff that that I I
think is going to have a very natural
um political base because you know like
no one cares about the you know jobs of
AI if you think about it it's like you
know it's like oh AI does more work it's
like you know I I
um I just care about human workers
um I so I'm very concerned about what's
going to happen in a lot of these
environments and organizations I think
we've got a triple whammy going
personally which is that we have this
move to remote work which puts
organizations in a sort of different
Bend in terms of like what they can do
and automating and then you have uh AI
coming online and everyone feeling like
you have to rush Palmetto to use these
tools and adopt them as as quickly as
possible and then the third part that I
would put out there is that now you have
like a more constricting Capital
environment with like Rising interest
rates and
um and the rest of it where people are
are going to feel like they have to
um like get ruthless about their uh
their cost structure so what do you
think is going to happen
in six months
I have no particular this is this is not
like a leading question where I have
like you know some Hammer to throw down
in my position on the six month letter
um I it was it was interesting to me and
I don't think I took a side
um but what could be done if you if you
agree the technology should be used and
you disagree with the decision to you
know ban it by places like Italy
and but you also think that there should
be a pause what do you think happens in
that six months that brings us into a
better situation when we come out of it
in September 2023. I contemplated that
very thing Derek when I was reading the
letter being like what can we do in six
months if we had our acts together uh so
number one I I thought that individuals
and organizations would get a better
read on what the heck AI would mean for
them their Staffing their jobs uh and
you'd be able to to make some like plans
and actions in that time an ideal
development would be that the government
said look we don't know what the heck is
going on in this space and we not we're
not even sure who's supposed to regulate
it really so what we should do is come
up with an actual AI regulatory uh
agency and hopefully framework uh and
have Congress throw down and say look
this is the agency that's going to be
responsible for it because this is a
very very important new development and
by the way there were some techies who
were calling for something similar
they're like we don't even know who the
X supposed to be running point on this
over there
um now
did I think that again like did I think
that the pause was likely to happen I
did not but I I did think well in the
ideal World we'd start rolling some some
kind of
um commission out uh that could round
people up and say okay guys what would
rules of the road even look like in in
this space
um because right now the incentives are
for the biggest tech companies to go as
fast as they can and that's right I
think the biggest incentives are if the
tech companies go as fast as they can I
I don't know yet like what the right
test is for these tools for example on
alignment how what is it what is what's
an SAT test that we could give these
large language models and apparently
they're very very good at taking sat
tests so we should have no doubt that
they could be able to finish it what's a
test we could give that would make us
certain that the tools are essentially
good and not bad or I guess to use the
lingo of the day aligned and not
misaligned
um likely to be aligned going forward
and less likely to be nefarious it seems
like we need more people working on
writing those tests and figuring out
what the questions should be because I
sometimes find that the debate right now
is between people who say you know pedal
to the metal let's just see how fast
this thing can go and you know there's
obviously not a particular like ethic
there that's just you know interest in
seeing how far
um you can shoot this slingshot but then
on the other hand I guess I just don't
know what the other side is hoping for
all the time and again I find myself not
even like refereeing this I mean I find
myself an interesting Observer of the of
this debate I'll give you an example of
something that that was immediate
University administrator said to me that
they're looking at going to oral exams
because it's the only way that they can
be confident you didn't use AI
um so how long does it take for
universities to come up with a new way
of testing students you know I mean
could you get that done in six months
Maybe
[Laughter]
um so there are different adaptations
that can be had when you talk about how
good these things are at tests the last
I saw was gpt4 could get a 90th
percentile score on the bar exam and
then 88th percent on the LSAT
um which is above average I mean you
know it's an above average like lawyer
score
um but the biggest thing is that we know
it's going to go from uh 88 to like 98th
percentile in six months but probably
we're just going to to put
uh put it ahead of uh you know all but a
handful of humans yeah it's possible
that it's very possible it happens maybe
it's probable that that happens
sometimes I wonder with artificial
intelligence and in particular these
Technologies whether there's going to be
a self-driving phenomenon and when I say
self-driving phenomenon I mean that you
know in 2015 2016 when I was writing a
world without work for the Atlantic and
when I was reading a lot about the
future of work and automation I was
pretty sure as I'm sure you were given
that I know that we were talking to the
same people uh that sell trading cars
really were right around the corner I
mean everyone that I talked to said we
are going to have autonomous Municipal
fleets right there's going to be a ton
of like cheap little electric
self-driving Vehicles the roads of you
know New York City Washington DC and
you'll hail them and they'll come right
to your door and they'll all sort of
like collect at the edge of the city
somewhere they can like you know hang
out between the hours of like you know
two and six in the morning and then
they'll they'll swarm back into the City
and they'll swing us around it'll be
absolutely like none of this came to
pass and I'm not saying none of it will
come to pass but like we got from zero
to 99 when it came to the technology of
automated vehicles and we just got stuck
at 99. it seems to me like we just
haven't been able to get to the point of
waymo has self-driving test pilot
projects in Arizona to this is in Los
Angeles this is in San Francisco to New
York and DC yeah I I did talk to a lot
of the same people
and and and uh you know like I I was
with you it's like I I was confident
that it was going to happen based on the
confidence of others that it was going
to happen and then it did not happen
um I I will say that on on this one the
thing that shook me up the most was the
gulf between gpt3 and gpt4 I mean it was
just so much better and stronger and
faster in a period of gosh like weeks uh
and so one of the things that someone
pointed out which I think is right
um there are a lot of environments that
have been hyped about automation that uh
are not happening and self-driving
Vehicles is a prime example
um but there are others too and they're
they're two major obstacles that they
face that Chachi PT does not face
um so number one is that you have uh
interaction with the real world and uh
um high stakes like environments where
it's like you can't accept like a 99.9
you know success rate on on like making
a left turn because that's how you know
like you crash at me whenever one
thousand left turns yeah yeah whereas
like you could accept those kind of
confidence intervals when you're like
writing uh you know an essay or a poem
great yeah um and then the the other
thing is that you you're running into
robotics limits um and real world
physical limits
um in a lot of these environments
um whereas you know these large language
models it's like whatever you know they
can just eat uh data points and just
just uh keep keep on going so I think
they've found like a very fertile Avenue
uh for uh you know for for these tools
to just run wild without uh you know
like having like a whole slew of
um major major legal problems and it's
probably right I think it's probably a
pretty good answer to the question of
you know will AI have the self-driving
car phenomenon
um I think I hadn't thought of of the
first although when you said it was like
oh yeah of course that's obvious like if
I um I sometimes I'll you know if I use
strategy BT for like research or
something I say like give me seven
papers
um on from economic history
about the degree to which technology
replaces human labor right and I'll get
like maybe six papers that are real and
one paper that's like a total misprint
and like one of the names is misspelled
like six out of seven ain't bad is my
response to that result this is a this
is a incredibly directionally useful
reply from a Chachi BT if you crash the
car six out of seven times you pull it
out of the driveway that's an utter
catastrophe so like yeah that seems like
a really really important point that I
hadn't quite thought of
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
so my concern level about this stuff is
is Sky High
um and one of the test cases I use is
call center workers
um which is like you you definitely
don't need genuine human intelligence to
like walk people through you know an
interaction at a level that's uh
probably better than you know at least
some proportionate human
like you know human call center workers
yeah the call center research seems to
pretty clearly it's funny call centers
for whatever reason have been both the
site of work from home experiments one
of the first work from home tests or a
surveys that was done by Nicholas Bloom
was on call centers
um and he found that working from home
actually did make some a lot of them
more productive
um and then also it's a seat of AI I
think in Partridge because the call
centers are it's so wrote right like the
work they do is like so repetitive that
I think it's easier to study
productivity I think it's really
interesting to think like
um you know it's mesh entering
productivity throughout the economy has
got to become it's just becomes so so
hard like think about
um I know many people you know in like
Hollywood
um or like you know like uh okay you
mean you move the executive you meet
like a new executive's assistant you'll
talk to maybe like a screenwriter you'll
talk to like some other you know
assistant producer and you're like
I've had seven lunches what's the
productivity rate of those lunches like
right like how many how many what
percent of a movie did we make in those
lunches what is the output of those
lunches there is none it's just lunches
lunches lunches it's just a ton of
conversations about projects that may or
may not come down the pike like that
kind of productivity is like very very
hard to measure and I guess I wonder how
decision makers and managers and chief
executives are going to make decisions
about replacing certain jobs with AI for
productivity based purpose when
productivity itself is something that's
like so so hard to measure like in many
of those Industries they're really like
hitmaker Industries
um where if you have like one enormous
movie where you create one incredible
franchise you can feast and feast and
feast on that one hit for years but so
that's obviously very productive but
there's no way to formalize that there's
really no like formula for it and so
like will llms be be able to get us
better franchise tentpoles right will
the next Marvel be written by an AI well
the next you know
um Harry Potter be written by an AI like
that's a really weird interesting
question because that's really where the
productivity of that part of the economy
flourishes I talked to someone in
Hollywood and they actually had chat GPT
for uh write a treatment for an
Espionage TV series and they said that
it was pretty good and that they then
used it and modified it and tweaked it
to try and do something real with it so
what's happening in a lot of these
contexts is it'll create something
that's like 82 percent of the way there
and then it takes a skilled experience
human to be like hmm like what am I
going to do with this like next eight
eighteen percent on the Hollywood topic
you put the you put the right word on it
which is projects everyone has a project
and then what everyone has multiple
projects that they're somehow attached
to and then one of the projects starts
gaining energy and momentum and
resources and then everything and then
what you do is you be like oh I've got a
live one and then you're like just like
turn to that one and start putting
energy into it uh I'm involved with a
couple of things that resemble that
actually and then when it starts to get
energy you're like wow look at that like
I've been on
um Hollywood pitches and uh like we're
you know going around and
um like reading our lines from a script
for you know these Network Executives
and that that is the way people measure
it really is like they were like okay
which of my projects is getting traction
yeah right yeah and there's right it
always is like 13 meetings in order to
get like two nipples and one of the
nipples is fake and the other one it's
it's a very it's a very strange industry
and I guess what I'm trying to say is I
do think that there's a lot of
Industries in this country
um where like and it's something that I
read about in the book the line between
working and not working is actually like
very hard to draw
um if I'm for example you know the same
way that if a a film executive is out to
lunch with a prospective writer who
hasn't written a screenplay yet but
they're talking about a treatment
they're talking about a plot or a story
that could become a successful script is
that working like yeah kind of clearly
you can you can expense it
um but it might not amount to anything
there might not be literally any
economic output from that meeting and I
feel like in the same way a lot of my
work is maybe it's true of a lot of
creative Industries I'll just be on
Twitter right and I'm not embarrassed to
say this I'm hanging out on Twitter and
I'm reading and I'm making jokes and I'm
replying to people and I
and you know uh you know outraged with
some things that I see and then I'm
really impressed by some things that I
see and maybe there's like a graph or an
article or a paper and I'll say Ah
that's my next Piece At what point of
that experience am I working or not
working like the whole thing is actually
in like this superposition of like
working and not working at the exact
same time and I think that a lot of
people in White Collar work a lot of
people in Creative Industries are like
this like that they do spend a lot of
their time in this like suspended the
super in the superposition of both
working and not working at the same time
um and I wonder what the inflection of
artificial intelligence is going to do
to that on the one hand it could make
work much more distracting it could mean
there's many more opportunities to spend
time both working and not working at the
same time
um but maybe you know the the utopian
vision is that it will make us much more
productive and purposeful at doing the
things that we know we have to do and as
a result we can get five days of work
done in three or four that means more
Leisure it means more time it means more
productivity more money for the economy
more money for us but also more leisure
time so I think this is one of the many
places uh with with sort of the way that
AI is inflecting the future of work that
I remain really interested to follow
yeah yeah that's the positive vision and
I greatly appreciated your message uh
that you put out I want to say it was
earlier this year where you said you
know what we need a politics of
abundance and and that is
um the ideal impact of AI is that
somehow it does free us up and it makes
us more efficient maybe we even start
using our time for other things because
we've shaken free of our work ISM
um to your point
um but I I'd love for you to close on
what the heck you meant by politics of
abundance because I I think it is
very much the opposite of a lot of the
politics we're getting nowadays like
we're getting a lot of uh scarcity and
can't do this and zero-sumness
um and you're you're trying to to
present a totally different approach I
think that the story of this Century in
many ways has been a story of
intersecting scarcities
one of the biggest problems the 21st
century is the lack of housing in many
Rich metros a scarcity of homes the
2010s were a period of the lowest levels
of construction per capita of any period
in recorded American history so we have
a shortage of homes we need to
decarbonize the grid we've got lots of
people especially on the left who are
saying we have to move to a carbon-free
economy get out cold get out gas get out
oil well you can't just remove
coal and gas and natural gas and oil and
still have a functioning economy you
have to replace it with solar and wind
and geothermal that means you have to
actually build solar wind geothermal
transmission lines if we want an
abundance of health care if one
abundance of access we should look at
the fact that America has the fewest
Physicians per capita of any country in
the oecd and one of the reasons for that
is that the American Medical Association
limits number of residency slots it
makes it very difficult for us to have
as many Physicians as we need so what
have I just said we have a scarcity of
housing we have a scarcity of clean
energy and we have a scarcity of
Physicians of doctors in America that's
where I want to see abundance I want
abundance in housing abundance and clean
energy I want abundance in health care I
love abundance and education that's
where abundance is good the problem of
the 21st century is what he is that
we've had an abundance of like the
internet makes it very easy to lie
disinformation misinformation nonsense
it got an abundance of that you know an
abundance of digital nonsense I want
more abundance in the physical world and
less abundance in the digital world well
that is a fantastic Clarion call Derek
Thompson on work money meaning identity
and one of my favorite thinkers and
writers on these topics which are near
and dear to my heart I ought to say uh
you know I've relied upon you heavily
this last number of years if someone
wants to keep up with you in your work
how can they best do so
uh yeah subscribe to the plain English
podcast follow my writing at the
Atlantic I'm at DK thump on Twitter uh I
guess those are three ways and do check
out this book of essays
um the thing I loved about this book of
essays is that they were very very deep
that it would be like a five-page thing
and I'd be like oh you know I can read
this pretty quickly but it's like oh
wait I can't read this really quickly
because they're actually like a lot of
very very important impactful ideas here
you know like if I really want to
understand them like I accept uh to sit
on them for a little bit so
congratulations on this man it's like a
compilation of some of your greatest
hits
um but I think people would enjoy it
immensely if they get their hands on it
I really appreciate that thank you
Andrew